remember getting Newsweek as a child I
look forward to it
I believe that Newsweek made me a
smarter kid it was like highlights with
war now the magazine just makes you
dumber once a noted publication it's now
a thinly pressed carcass of mind vomit
their latest an article by Melissa
Matthews called how murderer Charles
Manson and Donald Trump used language to
gain followers hold on
isn't that what Newsweek does use
language to gain followers isn't that
what Melissa Matthews does isn't that
what the New York Times does isn't that
what we all do does that make Newsweek
like Manson imagine how this story came
about a group of young editors close to
my age early thirties they're sitting
there sitting around there hoping for
any idea to take a naked Charlie Rose
off their minds it's like a hairless cat
on his hind legs smoking pipe now they
know their one paycheck away from
opening a cat sitting business in
Brooklyn
finally a [ __ ] says let's compare
Manson to Trump relief they break for
lunch
vegan wraps in green tea all around good
for them I say if you want people to
click on your free webzine which is what
Newsweek is saying Trump is Manson beats
all comers although in the article even
they admit that Trump really isn't
Manson they didn't buy it either and
they didn't expect you to buy that
either - that's why it's free so
Newsweek is now like the saddest
sideshow attraction the sign reads see
the caterpillar man and it's just a
junkie in a sleeping bag fact is even
they know they're peddling tripe but an
editor's got to eat they don't have the
words but they do have Manson so weird
it is weird dana jump in on this please
I loved Newsweek - growing up and this
sounds more like a PhD dissertation yes
an actual news article right and thank
you you can thank me when you get your
PhD that I gave you that idea but what
if they say that and they didn't have
specifics on what Manson may have told
followers but argued it was probably
similar to the rhetoric that other cult
leaders have used or maybe it's actually
just what people use to try to
to follow them at President Obama yes
appeal to people's emotions so you can't
fly this to anybody any leader any TV
personality like myself
who's quite persuasive and influential
that's right any politician is guilty of
being charismatic and preying on
people's emotions yeah they do this with
all Republicans though they've compared
Trump with Hitler to Isis to OJ Simpson
this was lazy clickbait it's a smear you
go to your editor and you're say I have
a Republican and we're gonna link him to
something evil and the editor says all
right give me three paragraphs done deal
you could do with Hillary easily Hillary
she's Teflon she gets away with
everything Oh Jay is like Hillary see
how easy that was
does that get me in the Newsweek though
no because it's not liberal Democrat
magazine one what happened to Newsweek I
love that magazine I knew that it was
trying very hard to beat time because
time was always like more successful but
I always liked the little brother that
news like Newsweek was always the little
brother to talk and then there was the
creepy US News and World Report that you
didn't know what it was it was like the
real boring version of it was like the
boring third brother was Jan Brady Brady
Greg Brady was time and Peter was
Newsweek explained my thoughts why you
could just have like best colleges in
the universe right and that's become new
yes that was good but Newsweek I don't
know what's going on there but I will
say this I mean you guys just basically
break it down as partisan attack on
President Trump and actually I thought
thought it's interesting here they are
saying charismatic language and frumps
use of language by the way is
interesting
he speaks in very emotive terms he uses
very simple words they make America
great again would be an example Locker
of the wall right very simple then what
that's like hope and change no no but
that's not the heart and soul of an
Obama speech it's not the soul of auxin
speech
no boring his speeches well no I like I
got Obama as a fine speaker but I don't
think he's a great but I think he's a
fine speaker but this metropolis
camera of Langdon oh by not but remember
his demographic you know what a lot of
people who didn't graduate from college
and that's very insulting that is okay
the guys use of language is fantastic it
has made him present the United States
that's a very successful American
entrepreneur as well as people who is
jealous that he's been able to connect
with people and he hasn't been you know
trapped by worrying about being
politically correct he's found an
audience out there and it resonates and
I think it's across multiple
demographics so that's what the article
said Kindle is that he's charismatic but
he gets people to accept an ideology
regardless of whether and here I'm
quoting destructive or dangerous that's
that articles opinion that's all
scientific that's what we're supporting
is the man won the election because he
was able to connect with all people not
just people that actually felt that they
were left behind that no one was
listening to them that no one was
speaking to them no one cared if they
had food on the table or money in their
wallet or they could put gas in their
car or they were coal mine workers that
were getting put out of work so they
said well this guy's listening to me so
I'm gonna pay attention the popular vote
[Music]
years later with regret an admission we
still don't know what happened that's
right don't get it all right ahead